Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says Iran was lying when it said it sold
drones to Russia only before the
invasion of Ukraine Moscow says it's
been using only russian-made drones in
the conflict
with accusations Rife that Iran is
supplying Russia with drones in its war
with Ukraine Iran's foreign minister
offered his most detailed remarks to
date at a defense meeting in Tehran
regarding the outcry started by some
Western countries saying the Islamic
Republic of Iran has provided Russia
with missiles and drones to help it with
the war in Ukraine the missile part is
completely false the Drone part is true
we gave a limited number of drones to
Russia months before the Ukraine war
planade
not true says Ukraine's president who
claims that his troops are shooting down
10 iranian-made drones daily and that
the supplies are ongoing
Vladimir zielinski issued this warning
to Tehran
if Iran continues lying above the
obvious it means that the world will
make even more efforts to investigate
the terrorist cooperation between the
Russian and Iranian regimes and what
Russia is paying Iran for such
cooperation these terrorists or their
accomplices cannot remain unpunished in
the modern world
there has been a surge of drone attacks
in Ukraine in recent weeks targeting
energy and civilian infrastructure
Western countries have imposed sanctions
on Iran over alleged sales of the
weapons to Russia
Moscow claims that the drones it uses in
combat are russian-made and not of
Iranian origin
Iran's foreign minister says that if
there is proof that that's not the case
Tehran will not remain indifferent
let's bring in Russia analyst
Constantine Eggert who's joining us from
Vilnius in Lithuania
um Constantine in your assessment how
big a difference are these drones making
in the kremlin's war on Ukraine
Michael to do make a difference these
drones are cheap some estimates go as
low as ten thousand dollars for per
piece they're relatively small the
wingspan is two and a half meters
imagine you can basically assemble it in
your living room
um so they and and they seem to be
effective especially uh against
um static targets and Russia has
definitely been using them to deplete
Ukrainian high-tech Weaponry on the one
hand on the other hand definitely to
attack the civilian infrastructure and
this is I think what is very important
because now with
um the crown and Ames being always vague
but now being basically what can be
achieved uh it seems that Moscow is
betting on such destruction of Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure especially
energy infrastructure that Ukraine will
sue for peace and I think that in this
disrespect Iranian drones are quite an
effective quite an effective weapon
according to the Washington Post the U.S
has been privately encouraging uh
Ukraine to Signal an openness to
negotiate with Russia as the paper put
it do you see any chance that Putin is
interested in negotiations
well Putin is always interested in
negotiations on his own conditions and
if Washington indeed tries to encourage
the government of Vladimir zielinsky to
uh to to to to open some kind of channel
to Moscow then I actually also believe
it too because it seems that the U.S
Administration which is really committed
to supporting Ukraine is starting to
understand that uh basically the
destruction of uh Ukrainian civilian
infrastructure and possible humanitarian
consequences of of this uh Russian
action could weigh very heavily on
Washington's support for Ukraine and
especially that is especially important
in view of the upcoming midterm
elections where quite a few isolationist
Republicans may start criticizing or
actually questioning uh the uh the White
House's policy so I do believe that
there is a possibility that the U.S is
privately urging zelenski to start
talking to Putin and be in such
circumstances Putin will see it is
Ukraine's weakness and will try to take
uh advantage of that Russia analyst
Constantine egart many thanks
thank you